hey everyone
[Applause]
if it's cool with you i'm just going to
draw for a little bit
story has always helped me understand
the human experience
growing up
i took solace in the books that i would
read and those book characters that i
met
offered me friendship
characters like ralph s mouse from
beverly cleary is the most on the
motorcycle
snoopy garfield
they offered me companionship as i dealt
with
the trauma
of
my mother's lifelong struggle with an
opioid addiction
the fact that i didn't know who or where
my birth father was
story has also helped me
understand my family's history
my grandfather
who raised me
would hold court in the living room
regaling me with stories of life during
the great depression
and telling me all about his parents
who had emigrated
from poland
now my great-grandparents died
many years before
i was ever born
but through these stories that were
shared
in our home
i always felt like i knew them
now creating my own stories
that offered me an escape portal
you see it was a home that was
filled with so much dysfunction my
grandparents drank a lot
there was a lot of
yelling it's a lot of chaos
and i controlled none of it
from the pages of my comics
i was the one calling the shots
creating my own worlds creating my own
characters
sharing them with my friends
and family members
i thrived off that creativity
now my mother
was an incredibly talented artist
and even though she spent
the majority of my childhood
incarcerated
she spent her time
drawing cartoons
and mailing them to me
and these cartoons that arrived from
prison from my mom
it was her way of you know it was her
way of
letting me know that she loved me
and letting me know just what
i was capable of
now bearing witness to the stories of
others helped me put life into
perspective
when i was a teenager
i volunteered at a camp for children
with cancer
and i spent several summers after that
working there as well and of all the
kids i met over the years the kid that
sticks out the most in my memory is eric
eric was the very first kid that i was
charged to care for
i was 16 years old
he was four
and had recently been diagnosed with
leukemia
now
despite
his thinning hair
despite
the shunt in his chest
this boy wielded a power rangers sword
and went after life
with so much energy and an ear to ear
grin
now in my years of
working with a kid with critical
illnesses at camp you know i was often
lauded but that just always felt
unnecessary and backwards because it
just felt like such a selfish endeavor i
was given
a front row seat
some of the most remarkable stories in
human history
eric died
shortly before
his sixth birthday
25 years ago
and when there isn't a day that i don't
think about him there's a day that i
don't think what he meant to me or and
what he was able to do with his short
life and i do remain in touch with his
family
when i visit his gravesite
i don't bring flowers
i bring a power rangers action figure
i've recently completed a graphic memoir
recounting my time
working at camp
and working with this population
and that time with eric
now creating graphic memoir
is a daunting
experience
there is of course the physical labor of
a book that is hundreds of pages long
that has multiple
panels of art
on every single page
but it's the emotional toll that is the
most difficult to deal with
i'm face to face
with these loved ones that i miss i'm in
that room again and often
for the first time dealing with stuff
i'd never dealt with
at the time
now i went into this process knowing
full well
how intense this experience would be i'd
previously created a graphic memoir
called hey kiddo about my own childhood
and my mother's addictions
so
i know what you're all thinking
books for kids about a parent with
heroin addiction
pediatric cancer
and yes i am just chasing all of the hot
trends in children's literature
but when i was working on hey kiddo
even though the most important people
in my life had since passed my
grandfather my mother
production on that book
brought me closer to them
and the same now has happened
with eric
via sunshine
we all have loss
in our lives and we all have pain in our
life and that can be so incredibly
difficult
and and i know all too well that
no matter how much i talk about these
people no matter how much i write about
them no matter how much i draw them
there is nothing that i'm going to do
that's going to bring them back to this
earth
i miss them
but i take solace in knowing that their
stories are being shared and that they
are being remembered because my
grandfather my grandfather was right
stories keep people alive and real to us
thank you
you